here in Europe allegations of bribery
and Corruption within the highest
Echelon of law making have sent shock
waves across the continent the arrest of
Eva Kaylee our senior vice president of
the European Parliament on suspicion of
accepting money in exchange for giving
Qatar good publicity has raised
questions about just how much influence
the Gulf State May wield on the
continent it has also Shone a light on
the country's business ties with Europe
so let's take a look then at that
relationship last year qatar's exports
to the EU amounted to almost 7 billion
euros the vast majority of that
unsurprisingly was gas going the other
way the EU sold goods worth around 8.5
billion euros to Qatar the main exports
there were machines turbines and
electronic equipment Qatar has also been
investing heavily in a range of European
businesses the country holds a quarter
of British carrier iag it has a 17 stake
in Germany's Volkswagen and it's also a
major shareholder in Swiss mining Giant
glencore and Spanish energy conglomerate
ebitdroller those Investments suggesting
the country is setting its sights on a
future with less Reliance on gas
for more on this we can speak now to
Andre Wolfe he's a researcher at the
center for European policy I think tank
hi Andre lovely to see you now you have
conducted extensive research on qatar's
business ties with Europe based on what
you have found how big an influence do
you think Qatar wields on the continent
but what you can certainly say is that
qatar's economic engagement in Europe is
very comprehensive and widespread among
countries and sectors they're not just
investing in finance or certain
high-tech sectors they also invest in
soft sectors like fashion and sports and
in many cases they in their Investments
reach a critical level that allows them
to exert a strategic influence on
certain key players and sectors and at
the same time of course there's also
their role as the second largest supply
of LNG which will remain a bridge
technology for Europe in its a quest for
achieving its energy transformation so
in relation to their size their
influence is quite remarkable even
though it does not reach the level of
criticality we see for instance in case
of China
exactly just as you say Qatar is a
really small country it's very rich of
course but why do you think it is so
interest in boosting its its image in
Europe what exactly does it want
I see two main interests of Qatar in
Europe first I think they see investment
in Europe's economy as a means to hedge
against the price risks they are facing
in the LNG business so they use Europe
as an opportunity to diversify the
foreign resources and foreign revenues
which is essential for the Qatari
government to maintain the generous
support to the local population
while at the same time there's obviously
also the desire to increase their
reputation and recognition in the
international Arena through engagement
in popular activities like sports for
instance possibly with a long-term goal
to conclude something like a
comprehensive free trade agreement with
the EU
okay so based on all that I'd love to
end with a personal question when you
heard news of this corruption Scandal
what was your gut response were you
surprised as the rest of us were
honestly I was very surprised because I
would have expected them to choose ways
that are less risky and less obviously
illegal in increasing their political
influence in Europe especially given the
allegations they already faced in the
past surrounding the awarding of the
World Cup I can only imagine that sort
of underestimated the role of control
mechanisms at a critical public in the
European political system but of course
we need to wait for the further
investigations will tell
fascinating stuff and revolved from the
center for European policy thank you so
much
you're welcome